There super soldiers just running loose
great i got a vibranium arm I
could take them. That little girl kick your
our country is vulnerable we
need new heroes get in that's not happening
why didn't you use the metal on i don't always
think of it immediately i'm right-handed.
It's been a long journey there's always going to
be a darker side of this character but at the
same time it feels like this is the first time
he's finally free to kind of look after himself
but it's not easy he's just trying to kind of
do his best i got a vibranium arm i can take them
you drop something
I was wondering when you're gonna show up
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
falcon winter soldier episode 4 trailer video
and black panther breakdown bet you did not see
that cameo scene coming there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs obviously there's so much to talk
about including what's going on with the black
panther characters during the events of falcon and
winter soldier right after avengers end game so if
you're brand new to the channel i'm doing videos
for all the episodes be sure to subscribe to get
everything i'll be doing videos for all the marvel
disney plus series this year loki is gonna be the
next big one they're even doing a black panther
spin-off series on disney plus so i'm wondering
if this is also going to help set that up as well
i'll explain what's going on with that later in
the video too seems like pretty much every marvel
character is getting a disney plus series nowadays
but careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on falcon and winter soldier
in all the marvel disney plus series so far
like one division the marvel phase 4 stuff
but in the teaser for episode 4 florence kasumba's
ao character shows up in secret to contact bucky
letting him know that black panther has ordered
that he brings zemo back to wakanda and it's not
meant to be a polite request like she's not
there to ask him a favor like hey t'challa
is asking me to ask you will you please hand zemo
over to us that'd be really nice if you did that
remember how we're best buds now because you
spent all that time in wakanda white wolf
it does seem like they have a little bit of
history together i'll talk about that too during
the video but obviously the big implication
here is zemo black panther the dora melange
because she's dora milaje and what's happening on
falcon and winter soldier right now i just thought
it was interesting when he recognized her camoyo
beads that he recognized it was her specifically
and not just say wakanda in general showing up
like he didn't say i was wondering when wakanda
was going to show up he said i was wondering
when you were going to show up like he expected
her specifically to show up when he helped zemo
break out a prison but just backing up a second
first things first at this point in the timeline
if it wasn't clear black panther himself t'challa
is still alive after the events of avengers end
game it's only been a couple months after avengers
end game right now when the series is taking place
everyone share a moment of silence for chadwick
boseman though may he rest in power kevin feige
already explained how they're going to handle his
passing with the next black panther 2 movie that
ryan coogler is working on right now that movie
is going to be coming out next year they're going
to start filming it sometime this summer i believe
he said in his big presentation they're not going
to recast the role of t'challa it will always be
chadwick boseman but eventually they will pass the
mantle of black panther like they've done in the
comics it's implied that it'll happen during black
panther 2 at some point i've already done a video
for that big black panther 2 teaser they released
earlier this year so i'll post a link for that at
the end of this video and in the description
with all the details on the new story for that
movie how they're changing things just to address
chadwick boseman's passing but they won't actually
get into what happens with t'challa next in the
mcu during marvel phase four until the events
of black panther ii and because that movie won't
take place until next year later in the timeline
all this stuff on falcon and winter soldier Wandavision the earlier marvel phase 4 movies like
spider-man 3 no way home even doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness all this stuff takes
place before t'challa theoretically passes on
to the ancestral plane however marvel is going
to actually address t'challa dying in the mcu a
lot of what's happening with the black panther
falcon winter soldier crossover story also about
the events of captain america civil war and what
a coincidence during that movie is very timely
that black panther said death is not the end
for my people it's more of a jumping off point
he was talking about a higher cosmic existence
in the ancestral plane they really didn't get into
that too much during the black panther movie they
just show you the ancestral plane like they show
you that t'chaka's spirit is still alive in the
ancestral plain and using the heart-shaped herb
t'challa was able to visit that place briefly so
just think about that when you're thinking about
what happens with the t'challa character in the
mcu there's ways to bring him back without having
to do a carrie fisher force awakens situation
which marvel said that it will not do like they've
already confirmed we're not going to do a deep
fake version of chadwick boseman on screen either
way t'challa black panther is still alive right
now when this scene is happening and he would have
been the one to send ao the door milaje to collect
baron zemo and bring him back to wakanda to face
their judgment for killing king tachaka during
civil war so quick refresher if you don't remember
exactly how that went down baron zemo's whole plot
to split up the avengers hinged on framing bucky
for the death of t'chaka he made it look like the
bomb was planted by him then the next step was to
use the hydra commands to force him to escape and
go on a rampage taking out most of the avengers
and including black panther knowing that captain
america his friend bucky's friend would try to
stop them from retaliating in that coupled with
the revelation that captain america had hidden
the truth from iron man about bucky killing his
parents all this time that'd be enough to destroy
the team metaphorically and it was successful at
least for a little while funny how giant purple
space hitler thanos with the infinity gauntlet
will bring everyone together make them set their
differences aside but when black panther learned
the truth about what zemo had done he threw
him back in prison instead of revenge killing
him that was the whole message at the end of the
film like revenge will not solve this problem it
will not make me feel better he was trying to do
things by the book so to speak but now of course
zemo has escaped prison escape judgment and
is waltzing around the world free and clear
because he's a baller apparently he did say he was
royalty an actual baron that's why they call him
baron zemo in the mcu until he says the avengers
destroyed his country and apparently that's where
black panther draws the line like we were willing
to let you rot in their prison now that you're
not doing that you're running around the world
escaping judgment you have to come back to wakanda
if there's anyone that could devise an inescapable
prison it would definitely be the wakandans
zemo kind of referenced wakandan prison when
winter soldier came to see him he said at least
you were not conscious for your imprisonment
talking about bucky being put in cryo storage
in wakanda when shuri was deprogramming him
technically that was not meant to be prison that
was meant to be a mercy for him just to prevent
him from doing anything that he didn't want to do
so the whole conflict now that they're teasing
this drama between falcon and winter soldier in
black panther wakanda the dora milaje ao is that
they can't let them take zemo because they need
him to stop the flag smashers from using the rest
of their super soldier serum they stole there are
12 vials left the other thing they're teasing here
though is that winter soldier knows ayo a little
better than he's letting on like he maybe got to
know her during his time in wakanda the other door
milaje i'm sure too as if they're friends somehow
or they have some history together that weaves
through the time between captain america civil
war in avengers infinity war buggy was snapped
so he wouldn't have been hanging out with any of
them during that five year time jump but the way
the children in that black panther post credit
scene talk about him like the white wolf like
they're really enamored with him or fascinated
by him seems like he'd developed his own little
fan base while he was there like there's some
whole story about his time in wakanda that they
just haven't got to yet one of my favorite
black panther winter soldier jokes too from
the earlier episodes was when falcon was teasing
him about being white panther like oh you come out
of wakanda feeling like white panther but then
bucky corrects him and says no it's white wolf
like he didn't know that bucky got a cool wakanda
name like oh i want a cool wakanda name too so i'm
assuming during episode four when ao is around a
little bit more for more scenes they'll hint at
more of his time in wakanda that they haven't got
into yet i don't know if she's only going to be
here for episode four or if she's gonna come back
after that in more episodes they tease like a real
big tear-jerker cameo scene during episode five
and a lot of people are like does that mean that
chadwick boseman is actually gonna cameo on falcon
winter soldier i'm not expecting that just because
when they were filming falcon winter soldier
episodes was when chadwick boseman's cancer
had gotten really really bad so i don't think he
would have been able to actually film episodes for
that i think it's more likely that they're going
to do some flashback scenes for isaiah bradley's
version of captain america back in the 1950s
during the korean war notice when they introduced
his character carl lumley is actually in old
age makeup they made him look way older than
he actually is because he's not that old in real
life so i think because it's so easy for marvel
to de-age characters like they de-aged robert
downey jr back during captain america civil war
and they've gotten better since then like ant-man
and the wasp they just did the same thing with
mark hamill on the mandalorian for the big luke
skywalker cameo scene so i think it'd be really
easy for them to de-age carl lumley just a little
bit and do a big flashback to actually showing him
as captain america back in the 1950s or a version
of captain america in the whole tearjerker part of
it that they're teasing will just be showing you
what actually happened to him after all that went
down but terrible things that the government did
to him they teased that he wrecked winter soldier
something fierce during their big fight so i'm
hoping that that's the scene that they show show
him just beating the crap and ripping half of his
arm off but like i said i'm also kind of hoping
that they have this black panther crossover story
line here to tease some of the new black panther
spin-off series for disney plus so if you didn't
see it earlier this year they announced that ryan
coogler signed this bigger deal with disney and
marvel to develop tv series on the sly for disney
plus in addition to doing more black panther
sequels the way they called it is that it would
be something like a world of wakanda series with
the major characters from the black panther movies
they didn't say exactly what the story would be
but you have to imagine that this is just getting
into that the idea that wakanda the dora milaje
their forces are very active around the world
they just haven't fully paid that off in the mcu
yet like at the end of the black panther movie you
have him buying all those buildings setting up the
resource centers all over the world they haven't
really followed up on that since the events of
the black panther film a couple years ago i'm also
assuming that the black panther disney plus series
whatever that winds up being will also feature the
next version of black panther whoever they wind
up passing the mantle to whether they go the comic
book route and pass the mantle to shuri because
she's the next in line for succession to take the
throne of wakanda or if they go the multiverse
route and bring back michael b jordan as the
killmonger of an alternate universe who just grew
up differently became a hero and then took the
mantle of black panther in his universe michael
b jordan did say that he would love to come back
for black panther too so there is a way that could
wind up happening but kevin feige and ryan coogler
haven't really responded to questions about that
but everyone post your black panther crossover
theories in the comments below what do you think
is going to be happening with them coming for zemo
and if there are any other big questions or easter
eggs that you want me to do videos for just let me
know in the comments below i'm still a little
behind on videos i have a new godzilla vs kong
easter egg video that i'll try to post next
while you wait for everything click here for
that black panther 2 teaser that marvel released
and click here for my full falcon winter soldier
episode 3 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!